[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I'm very excited to
have this guest here, Mr. Mike
Posner.
Since 2009, he's been a
household name in music.
"31 Minutes to Take Off," his
debut album, was incredible.
"At Night, Alone" number 12
on the Billboard Top 200.
You might know him from
hits like "Cooler Than Me,"
"Please Don't Go," "I
Took a Pill in Ibiza,"
which got 1.5 billion
streams worldwide.
You might not know
that he's actually
responsible for hits
like "Sugar" by Maroon 5
and "Boyfriend" by
Justin Bieber, as well.
And then, what I want
to really focus on here
is his new podcast,
which is incredible.
It's called, "What
Does This All Mean?"
And he asks really deep kind
of existential questions,
meaningful questions.
He brings incredible
kind of spiritual people
like Deepak Chopra, like
Sharon Salzberg on his podcast.
He talks about what the meaning
of life is, and meditation,
and how to make yourself
feel good every day.
And it's incredible.
It's almost like a
modern "Meditations"
by Marcus Aurelius.
Because this is a guy who's in
the arena, he's making music,
he's making hits.
But he's also talking about
the most important questions
in life.
So I'm really excited to have
him here and get started.
Thank you, Mike, for coming.
MIKE POSNER: Thank you
for that sweet intro.
SPEAKER: No problem.
MIKE POSNER: I'm excited too.
SPEAKER: Cool.
So why don't you just
give us a little bit
of context, two
to three minutes,
your childhood until now, just
so the audience kind of knows.
MIKE POSNER: Dang,
two to three minutes?
Let's see I was born
in Detroit, Michigan.
I lived there until I was
2, when my family moved
to Southfield,
Michigan, which is
a suburb that borders Detroit.
And a lot of people are probably
familiar with the film "8
Mile," but they may not
know the significance
of the road, 8 Mile.
8 Mile's a huge road.
It's a main road,
and it's significant
because it is the border
between Detroit and the suburbs.
So I lived right on the
other side of 8 mile--
12 Mile, in the city
called Southfield.
Southfield's a special place.
Demographically, it's
pretty similar to Detroit,
though, I would say,
economically, it's a little--
people are a little more
well-off in Southfield.
But it's a largely
African American city.
And I grew up there and
got into hip hop music
when I was very young.
And when I was in
middle school, I
remember having a sleep over
at my buddy's house, Ronnie,
and my other friend
Aaron Webster were there.
And we all gathered up CDs
that had no words, only music,
and we were all going
to try freestyling.
And we all were in the
basement, and we were rapping.
And they were
like, that was fun.
And I just knew I was not
going to stop doing that, ever.
And I haven't really.
SPEAKER: There you go.
MIKE POSNER: So yeah.
I went to finish
high school there,
and I went to college
at Duke University.
Shout out.
[LAUGHING] Go, Devils.
And when I got to Duke, I
started to sing my raps.
I had just rapped that whole
the time, and I also made beats.
And I got a little
ahead of myself.
But in Detroit,
right before I left,
I met this guy Sean who
I used to work with,
who later became Big Sean.
And I was part of his crew.
And so I went to Duke, and I
would make beats for Big Sean.
SPEAKER: How did
you meet Big Sean?
MIKE POSNER: I met Big
Sean because my mom told me
I had to get a job
after senior year.
And so I looked online.
I found that one of the hip
hop stations in Detroit--
it was called
HOT102.7 at the time.
I think it's changed names
and frequency since then--
was hiring interns.
So I went in, did an interview.
And there was line out the
door, and surprisingly, they
hired me.
And one of the other interns
was this rapper named Pat Piff.
And we worked together,
and we became really close.
And we used to
like fold T-shirts
and get people coffee
and stuff like that.
And Pat was in a group
with Sean at the time.
They were a duo.
And Sean had just
met Kanye, and, like,
they were courting each other.
And then I went to school.
And you know, to make
a long story short,
I started to sing my raps.
I don't know why.
Maybe it was the warmer weather.
And I just thought--
I thought it would be
cool to hear someone
sing the way I wanted
to hear a singer sing,
being a hip hop fan.
Because that's like--
I just loved hip hop.
So my first hit song, the
song, "Cooler Than Me"--
and it's got a sort of an
internal rhyme scheme, which
is atypical for a singer to do.
But very typical
for a rapper to do.
So what I'm talking about
is there's a line that goes,
(singing) you got
designer shades just
to hide your face face.
So not just-- it's not
just shades and face
that are rhyming, but
"designer" and "hide your"
are also rhyming.
And I just thought that
was dope because I didn't
hear people sing like that.
I heard people rap
like that, but I didn't
hear people sing like that.
And so I made a mix
tape in my dorm room.
That was one of the songs.
And Sean gave me three
verses for my mixtape.
A mixtape is like a free album.
And it's not done legally.
You just put it out for free.
And I found this sort of
loophole in iTunes U. ITunes U,
I believe it still exists.
But it was set up for professors
to put their lectures up
online for free.
And this was at the
height of pirating.
There was a few years in
there where pirating really
got out of control
before iTunes really
rescued the music industry.
And it was in that time.
And I was stealing everything.
I had the Duke internet.
SPEAKER: LimeWire and--
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
We used the BitTorrents.
And so I remember we had--
I remember getting--
we had Kanye,
"Graduation," a week early.
You get everything a
week early because that's
when the record labels will send
the music to the actual plants
to make the CDs.
So the plants had the music,
and they would leak it.
Anyways, I knew, if I'm
stealing Kanye's album,
I know no one's going to pay
for mine because no one knows
who I am.
So I found out who
ran iTunes U at Duke.
And his name was Todd Stabley,
and he was from Southfield.
So I was like, listen,
man, I'm a student.
I got this album.
And long story short, he let
me put my mix tape on iTunes U.
So you could go on iTunes
and search Mike Posner.
My mixtape would come up.
But this is the important thing.
It would come up,
and it was free.
You just click it.
It didn't have a price.
And that was a huge
catalyst for me
at the beginning of my career.
That, on top of the fact
that Big Sean gave me
three verses on that mix tape.
So people kind of
checked it out.
And I think people liked it.
That's a big part of it too.
You can have all those things in
place, and if no one likes it,
it doesn't really matter.
But I think--
I'd been making music
12 years at that point.
I think it was good.
It was good music.
And it took me 12 years to
make something like that.
It was my own before--
I'd have my Dilla month
and my Just Blaze month
and my Timbaland month.
And that definitely
had influences,
but it was
unmistakably my music.
SPEAKER: Right.
MIKE POSNER: And, yeah, that's
when my career got started.
SPEAKER: Did you have kind
of an "I made it" moment?
You have a really
great podcast episode
where you talk about
meeting Kanye a few times.
And you're very
nervous around him.
Then you meet Jay, who
actually signs you.
MIKE POSNER: Jay
did not sign me.
SPEAKER: He didn't sign you?
MIKE POSNER: He
came close, though.
SPEAKER: OK.
MIKE POSNER: He
made me an offer.
SPEAKER: OK.
Oh, he made you an offer?
OK.
Got you.
Was there a moment where
you were like, I made it.
This is it-- maybe being
in the office with Jay-Z,
or the release of "Cooler Than
Me" and it just blowing up.
MIKE POSNER: Well, yeah.
That's a funny thing.
All those moments had their
thrill that went with them.
But that's one of the things
I get into in the podcast,
is it seemed to really
be a moving target where
the thing that I thought
would be the "I made it"
moment felt good for
maybe an hour, maybe
a week, depending on
how big the thrill.
But then I felt the same.
My experience of
life felt the same.
And it's not that
my life got worse
when I got popular or more
well known or made more money.
It's that I thought it would
get better, and it was the same.
And that was very
disillusioning to me.
And I have a series of goals
and things I'm working on now.
But I know they're not really
going to change my life.
Like I want to win a Grammy.
I know I'm going
to get the Grammy,
and it'll feel cool
for a week or two.
And I'll still be me.
SPEAKER: If you have that
kind of broader outlook,
and you understand the
meaninglessness of material
things and progress
like that, what
motivates you at this
point in your life
now that you're
more [? kind of-- ?]
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
It's an interesting question.
And I'm not sure I have
the full answer to it.
Because there is a part of me--
and one of the questions I ask
on the podcast I don't
have an answer to--
that, I don't know
if anything matters.
I don't know if any--
people will say, like, well, we
have to solve global warming.
We have to solve
global warming if we
want humans to continue being
a species that's alive, right?
But I'm unclear as to
why that matters if we're
a species that's alive or not.
You see what I'm saying?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MIKE POSNER: And how do we
know that's a good thing?
It could actually
be a bad thing.
We might be in the
way of something else.
And I think, if
I had the answer,
I would probably say
it's not good or bad.
It just doesn't matter.
So, yeah, it's interesting.
It's like, how do you
organize your life
when is desire enough?
It's like, I want to do this
thing or experience this thing.
So is that how I
organize my life?
I'd go chase all the things
I desire, and organize,
and then it's over one day.
I don't know.
SPEAKER: Were you always
asking these questions?
When you were on the
come-up and just trying
to make it in music,
were you also thinking
about these larger existential
and spiritual questions?
MIKE POSNER: Not so much.
If anything, I feel I've had
the privilege to ask them now.
Because people-- like, I'm
sure everyone in this room
has been told money doesn't
buy happiness, right?
If you haven't been told that
directly, you've heard that.
And I was told that
directly by my parents.
And when people would say
that to me, I would nod.
But in my head, I
would think you just
didn't make enough money.
You didn't make it
past the threshold.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm going to
make more than you.
So fast forward to like age 22.
I was a multimillionaire.
And like I said, my experience
of life didn't change.
So I got the privilege of
asking, if not that, then what?
And people have different
theories about "then what?"
I'm not here proselytizing
for any of them.
There's some things that
I do in my life that
seem to make me happier.
But I don't think they're
the capital T Truth
or the only one,
the correct way,
because I don't
think there is one.
I wish there were.
It would be more simple, right?
SPEAKER: Right.
MIKE POSNER: But it's
nuanced, you know?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MIKE POSNER: Unfortunately.
It seems like you have a lot
of new, very interesting role
models that you bring
onto the podcast,
or spiritual teachers--
people like Deepak Chopra
and Sharon Salzberg.
Can you talk about maybe
two to three of those people
and what they mean to you?
MIKE POSNER: Deepak
to me means--
he's written something like 80
books or something like that.
I haven't read any of them.
I think I probably
will, at some point.
But I haven't yet.
I met him before
I got into his--
I listened to some of his is
YouTubes and stuff like that.
But for me, he means someone
who is on their sadhana--
which means, like,
spiritual path--
while in the world, like
in the thick of things.
I think he's done one of
these talks at Google.
He's not in a cave
somewhere, but he
seems to be doing the cave
work while being in the world.
So that's what he means to me.
Sharon, to me, means someone who
just has really done the work,
is doing the work, and
seems to live according
to her beliefs, which I respect
anyone who does that, even
when I don't agree with their--
I work with some artists that
are very sort of hardcore
Christians.
And I may not agree
with all their beliefs.
I actually agree
with some of them.
But I have respect for when
they actually live that way.
Like I know, OK, he
won't sing on a song
because I cursed in it.
I want to have him on the song.
But I really respect that
guy for actually saying no.
So I think of her in that way.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Nice.
So talk about your creative
process a little bit.
We were talking earlier.
And you were saying that you
just whip out the laptop,
and you just start
recording wherever you are.
Do you think that there's a
way to generate creativity?
Do you ever get
stuck and feel like I
can't make music right now?
MIKE POSNER: Sure.
I'm blessed I'm in a place where
I don't have to make any music.
And I try to be careful to
not just make music just
to make music.
I do because it's fun.
But I won't put something
out in the world just
to put something
out in the world
so people keep talking about me.
I want to do
something when I feel
like I have something to say.
So nowadays-- You know,
they talk about the Malcolm
Gladwell 10,000 hours?
I did that for music.
I wish there was other things
I had 10,000 hours in on.
But for writing songs, me in
the studio, I've done that.
And for some years I
would do a song a day--
record, produce, write,
everything finished.
And so I've gone through that.
And now I just wait until
it comes through me.
So I don't really
try to write anymore.
I just wait until
writing happens.
SPEAKER: What would you
say this new-- you're
making a new album, right?
MIKE POSNER: Correct.
SPEAKER: What would
you say it's about?
Just talk about what it
means to you, what you're
trying to express by making it.
MIKE POSNER: It's
trying to express
truth, the capital T Truth,
which is hard to do with words.
Because words are
symbols of reality.
So like the word water
is a symbol for that.
Or the word two
is a symbol for--
it isn't actually that.
It's a symbol for it.
Or Ramdas says, your words
are all fingers pointing
at the moon, they
are not the moon.
SPEAKER: Right.
MIKE POSNER: And
I personally feel
like I can get closer
to the Truth with music.
I think that's why I do it.
I've been trying to
get better at speaking.
But for a long time I felt--
I would hear myself
speak, like a recording,
or I'd see an
interview of myself.
And it felt like I was wearing
a costume, the way I spoke.
It seemed like the only way
I could really express or get
close to the Truth
was with music.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Well, I think you're
doing great today.
MIKE POSNER: Thank you, man.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So you spent like seven
days alone in a cabin.
And I think, like, day
five or six, you were like,
what would a world
without language be?
Was that what you were referring
to when you were, like,
it's a symbol for water.
It's not actually water?
MIKE POSNER: Well, yeah.
I think I went a little
further that day.
It was an interesting week, man.
So I had felt called to
solitude for a while.
I don't know why.
Part of me was just curious.
Part of me wanted to be able
to sound deep and cool when
I do stuff like this.
And part of me thought maybe
there was actually something
there for me to discover.
So I spent a week this
summer, or this past summer,
in a cabin on the property of a
Buddhist monastery in Colorado.
And they had a main monastery,
but this was up there.
It's set up for you
not to see anyone
and no one to see you for as
long as you want to be there.
So, yeah, so on the
fifth day, I started
to think more about language.
Because language is really
set up to differentiate.
It's there so we can
tell the difference
between the notebook
and the jeans
and the shoes and the hand.
That's what the words do.
Otherwise, it might just
be one [? hutch-- ?]
It's just reality.
So I realized, I'm sitting in
this cabin trying to experience
the oneness of the universe.
But my thoughts are in English.
So if I'm experiencing reality
through language, which
is set up to
differentiate, how could I
ever experience oneness?
And that begs the question.
Is there a way to think
outside of language?
Maybe you guys do.
I don't know how anyone
else's brain works.
But my thoughts, most of
them I think are in words.
They're in language.
So is there a way to
think outside of words?
I think there is.
And I think that, maybe, is
the most powerful technology
we could create,
is a way to switch.
Because there's no
doubt that language
is valuable for
other things, right?
But to experience unity,
maybe isn't so valuable.
Is there a way that we
can flip back and forth
between those two modes?
I don't know.
You guys should figure that out.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
You're at Google.
So we'll meet afterwards.
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
SPEAKER: "I Took
a Pill In Ibiza."
Can you take us through
the making of it,
what you were thinking
when you were writing it?
MIKE POSNER: Sure.
SPEAKER: And then how it
got picked up with the remix
and everything like that?
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
So I was in the studio with a
country artist, a wonderful guy
named Jake Owen.
You know Jake Owen?
SPEAKER: I don't.
MIKE POSNER: He's a
sick country singer.
You should check him out.
And he's popular right now.
SPEAKER: OK.
MIKE POSNER: He's one of
the bigger country artists
right now.
I know you're a hip hop guy.
SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah.
MIKE POSNER: Like me.
[LAUGHTER]
So Jake, he used to cover
a song from my first album
on his tour.
I guess he just liked it.
So we tweeted, ended up
going to this-- he was in LA.
He invited me come
to the studio.
So I went to the
studio with him,
and we're just hanging out.
And we're doing what we
call past the guitar.
I play a song for him,
pass the guitar to him,
he plays one, pass
it back, et cetera,
and just going back and forth.
I played him and
old tune of mine.
And he goes, I really
like this song.
What inspired it?
I said, it's about a girl I
had a thing with in New York.
And then some of it I
just kind of made up.
[CHUCKLE]
And he looked at
me-- yeah, exactly.
He looked at me, and he
goes, well, why don't you
just tell the truth?
I guess I looked sort
of quizzical back.
And he qualified it.
He said, you know
there's writers out there
that just tell the truth.
He goes, let me show you.
And he played me a
Hank Williams Jr. Song.
And he played me some old
Merle Haggard and these guys.
It actually felt
really hip-hop to me.
But in a lot of ways,
it connected with me
more because their stories--
well, it shared that
authenticity of hip hop.
If you're a rapper and you lie,
and people find out you lied,
it's kind of a big deal.
Like, If we find out Rihanna
doesn't write her songs,
we know that.
It's fine.
She's Rhianna.
She's an amazing artist.
But remember when
that thing came out
that Drake didn't write a song?
It's a huge deal, right?
It's like a scandal because
authenticity matters
in hip-hop.
It matters that you're
telling the truth.
And the same is true in country.
And so these guys, kind
of like Merle Haggard--
these guys will
tell these stories.
But their stories
sounded like my story.
Because it was like, oh,
I experienced this fame,
I fell off, and no one
cares about me now.
And it just blew my mind.
It blew my mind.
I left that studio,
and I was invited
to go with a friend to the
Winter Olympics in Russia.
I left.
I went on a plane.
And Jake had recorded
some of these songs
of him singing all their songs.
And I had the recordings.
And I was just listening to
them over and over again.
And this was on a plane that,
"I took a pill" just immediately
just kind of came out.
I wrote it down.
I think I meditated on the
plane, and some of the melodies
came.
I landed in Russia,
and I put chords
to what was in my notebook.
And then later, I thought
the song was done,
but it didn't have
the chorus yet.
So it didn't have-- (SINGING)
all I know besides--
wasn't in it yet.
And I was ready for a tour.
And I was going to play "I Took
a Pill in Ibiza" on the tour.
And I was rehearsing it
just alone in my house.
And I thought, man,
this song needs
a part the audience can
sing with me right away.
And then obviously no
one knows this song yet.
It's brand new.
I haven't even recorded it yet.
So while I was rehearsing for
the show, I made up that part--
(SINGING) all I know besides--
because I just wanted them to be
able to sing something with me.
And then that's when the song--
the writing was complete.
And you get a song that you
like, or a good recording--
I've written thousands
of songs in my life.
Probably less than
5% of the songs
I write go out in
the world because I
don't think all them are good.
SPEAKER: Do you just write
in a notebook all day?
MIKE POSNER: Yeah,
or some of them
are full songs I
write on the guitar,
or sometimes you
write to a beat.
So you make a beat first.
So I'm 29, and I
started when I was 8.
So it's 21 years of writing--
I've written all different ways.
Sometimes people say, do
you write a lyric first
or music first?
I'm like, I've
done it every way.
SPEAKER: Right.
MIKE POSNER: So anyways,
you get a song you like,
you think it's good,
I'll spend as long
as I need to on the recording
til I think it's right.
So it took a while to--
maybe five different versions,
productions of the song.
And I put out the
version I liked,
which I did in London
with Martin Terefe.
And that's a little
interesting about music
is you get a sound in
your head that you hear
the way it's going to sound.
And then you don't know where
that's going to take you.
Sometimes there's a
guy that has that sound
in San Francisco, or
New York, or London,
or wherever, Atlanta.
You don't know.
You chase it.
I ended up in London
because this guy,
he had the song I
heard in my head.
And we did the track.
And then I just went
back to practicing guitar
in my own world.
And I have these great guys
I work with out at my label--
Zeke and Matt.
And they called, and
they said, is it cool
if we get a remix done?
I said, of course.
Because on my mix
tapes, I always
remixed other people's songs.
And I was just doing my
thing, and I didn't really
pay attention to it.
And I had a really long beard.
I was living in my van
at the time in Utah.
And then my manager called.
He was like, that song, the
remix is number one in Norway.
I was like, that's interesting.
And it just kind of spread from
there and became this big song.
And so yeah.
I don't know.
I think I'm kind of lucky.
I write a lot of
songs, and my music I
make because that's the music
I want to exist in the world.
That's my job.
That's any artist's job.
You're supposed to create
what you want to be created.
And that's it-- not what I
think you would like to hear,
or you, or you.
And it gets a little muddy.
Create what I want,
and that's what I do.
And it seems, every once in a
while, a lot of people like--
there will be just some
random piece I make.
And it gets super popular.
SPEAKER: Do you feel
like you could tell?
Do you know--
MIKE POSNER: No.
I know when it's good to me.
And when I wrote that
song, I was proud of that.
But I'm proud of a
lot of stuff I make.
So I didn't-- no, I didn't
think it would be on the radio.
I put a drug reference
in the title.
So I didn't think it
would be on the radio.
SPEAKER: Right, right.
Do you think maybe that was part
of it, the controversy element?
MIKE POSNER: It
probably didn't hurt.
I knew that naming it that--
if I saw it, I felt like I
would want to click on that.
SPEAKER: Right.
MIKE POSNER: But I didn't think
it would play on pop radio
ever for that reason.
SPEAKER: Right.
Can you talk about some of your
musical influences in general?
We were talking about it
earlier, but from Detroit,
and then in general
outside of Detroit as well.
MIKE POSNER: Man,
there's so many.
It's a really tough
question for me.
And I don't want to dodge it.
But what's going to happen
is there's just so many.
SPEAKER: Could I
maybe confide to--
I'm a hip-hop guy, so hip hop?
MIKE POSNER: Totally.
We could do a top five.
SPEAKER: Top five.
Yeah, what's your top five?
MIKE POSNER: Dead or Alive?
SPEAKER: Dead or Alive.
MIKE POSNER: OK.
Nas, Three Stacks, Eminem.
Oh, I'm running out.
See, I want to say Pac,
and I want to say Biggie,
and I want to say Jay-Z. But
I only have two spots left.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So who's going to be in
[? the-- ?] you can't do six.
MIKE POSNER: This is
always what happens, right?
I'll do Pac and Hoba.
SPEAKER: Wow.
So you left Biggie out?
MIKE POSNER: I left
Biggie out this time.
My top five is kind of fluid--
SPEAKER: Yeah, OK.
MIKE POSNER: --today.
SPEAKER: Do you still
do any rapping, or--
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: OK.
MIKE POSNER: I still
rap, especially--
I have a band separate from
my music called Mansions.
And Mansions is a duo.
It's me and Blackbear.
We have one album out.
We put it out in March.
I rap a lot on that album.
And it's probably my best
record that I've been a part of.
Just yeah-- it's a great record.
I'm really proud of that one.
SPEAKER: What are your top books
or philosophies or books that
have inspired you?
MIKE POSNER: Top books.
Whenever someone's
going through something,
and they ask me a question,
I always say "Alchemist."
You can read it in a day.
I know 99.9% of the people
that read it will like it.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Do you believe in that concept
of manifesting your fate?
MIKE POSNER: I do.
I do believe in the
law of attraction.
I really do, which,
in essence, is
you get what you think about.
But there's a subtlety
to it, which is--
for example, if I want to have
another hit song, if I think
about I'm going to have another
hit song, the law of attraction
says I'll get it.
But if I think about--
I don't have it yet, when
is it coming, what's wrong,
why isn't it here yet--
I'll get more of what's wrong?
Why isn't it here yet?
I'm manifesting that.
So there's a subtlety to it.
And I do believe in that.
And it kind of makes
sense, like rationally,
without the woo woo of it.
If I'm focused on what I want,
and these kind of opportunities
show up in my life, I'll be more
apt to notice them and chase
them.
I see them as opportunities.
Whereas, if I'm in a
pessimistic mindset,
I may not even walk through that
door because it doesn't matter.
So I do believe in that.
So some of the books that--
one, kind of my
story of believing
in more than I can see with
that goes back to Big Sean.
So after we did a mixtape,
and a couple of years pass,
my career leapfrogs his.
And he was stagnant for a while.
And his music--
he'd been signed,
like, five years, nothing
was really happening,
and then all of a sudden, boom.
His career explodes.
And I went to see him in the
studio one day in Hollywood.
And he was just glowing.
You ever around a
person, and you just
feel really good
around-- and they
make you feel good
just by being-- they're
not doing anything special.
It was like that.
And I went over to his
studio the next day.
And I was like, what's
up with you, man?
What?
He's like, you got to
read these two books.
The first one was
"The Alchemist."
The second one was
"Ask and It Is Given,"
by Esther and Jerry
Hicks, which is all
about the law of attraction.
And those two books are--
I don't know if
he still does it.
But he used to carry
that, "Ask And it
Is Given" with him everywhere.
SPEAKER: Wow.
MIKE POSNER: He had on in his--
and it would all be worn out
and stuff.
And I've seen it work.
My career, after
my first album, I
put out my first single, which
was that song "Cooler Than Me,"
which I talked about earlier.
And it was his big hit
all over the world.
And I thought that's what
happens when I put out singles.
And so I put out another one.
And everyone would tell
me, like, it's a rare thing
to happen.
But I was one for one.
I'm 100%.
So I put out my next one.
It was a little less popular.
Than my next one was a little
less popular than that.
And slowly, my popularity
started to wane.
And at the time--
it was interesting.
We were talking, like--
my self-identity was really
wrapped up in being popular,
like, the guy.
Well, then it
started to disappear.
And so I was like, OK.
I'm still alive.
But how I think of myself,
who I am doesn't apply.
I'm not popular really anymore.
So who am I?
And I had to figure that out.
And I started telling this story
because my artist's career was
really considered over.
I was considered a one-hit
wonder, which I was.
And I was what, we call it in
the music industry, shelved,
which means you're on a
label, but they have no plans
of releasing your album.
You're just kind of stuck.
And to everyone
else, it was fun.
It was over.
But I would meditate everyday,
and I'd visualize it.
And somehow I tricked
myself into thinking no.
I'm going to have
another big song.
I'm going to play
on Jimmy Fallon.
I'm going to win the
song of the year Grammy
or the album of the year Grammy.
It was like one of those two.
And I would just
focus on seeing it.
And my mom would call.
She's like, you
off that label yet?
I'm like, no, Mom, but
it's all going to work out.
Every week she would call.
You off that label yet?
No, Mom, but it's all
going to work out.
You off that label yet?
No, Mom.
Did you call your lawyer?
Yeah, I called my lawyer.
But it's all going to work out.
And it took a year, two years,
a lot of practicing my guitar,
and doing my music, but
I had another hit song.
I played on Jimmy Fallon,
and I got nominated
for song of the year Grammy.
All this stuff, I wrote it down.
It all happened,
except I didn't win it.
Lost it to Adele.
SPEAKER: It's a good
person to lose it to.
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
But it was like--
you know what I mean?
So I do believe in that stuff.
And I do believe I'll win one of
those at some point in my life.
SPEAKER: Putting it
out in the universe.
MIKE POSNER: Yeah, I believe it.
SPEAKER: It sounds like
that kind of down period
made you more stoic as well.
Like you talk about in your
podcast, you make songs now,
and you're just like, I don't
know what's going to happen,
but it's just about the process,
and putting it out there,
and you being into the song.
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
It's an important distinction.
When I was younger, I was in
high school, and I would rap,
and I would do battles.
And I skipped over that
in my two or three minutes
because I only had two
or three minutes then.
I would do battles,
you know like Eminem.
Like during the football
games, I'd be battling.
I was really small then.
SPEAKER: Did you
ever battle Big Sean?
MIKE POSNER: I
never battled him,
but we'd freestyle
a lot together.
We'd actually
freestyle on the radio
together in Detroit every
Friday, Freestyle Fridays.
SPEAKER: Do you think
you're better than him?
MIKE POSNER: Not now.
But then, yeah.
I thought I was.
And I'm bias.
Because hip hop is competitive.
So yeah, 2006 Mike
versus 2006 Sean--
I think 2006 Mike
was better for sure.
But that's my hip hop side.
And it's my brother,
you know what I mean?
I wouldn't be in the chair
if it wasn't for him.
But yeah, now, I think
he's another level.
I think he's one of the
best in the world, period.
And I don't rap
that much anymore.
So he's leapfrogged me
by a lot in that arena.
But that bombastic mentality
helped me in that period
because Sean got
signed before me.
And because I thought I
was better than him, when
he got signed by Kanye
and Island Def Jam,
I knew I was going
to get signed too.
I was like, that's my buddy.
He made it real.
So I thank him all
the time because he
made it real for all of us.
You know, that can be done.
SPEAKER: That can happen, yeah.
MIKE POSNER: That can happen.
And if you believe
in law of attraction,
it couldn't have happened
unless I started to believe it.
And I wouldn't have believed
it until I saw him do it.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Are there daily habits that
you do that get you going,
keep you inspired?
MIKE POSNER: My daily routine
looks something like--
if I'm really in the
zone, like I want to be,
I'll wake up at 5:30.
Sometimes like 6:45.
But I wake up at 5:30.
The first thing I
do is drink a huge--
I always keep water
right next to my bed.
I drink a huge thing of water.
We always drink gallon--
and call them G's.
We have a gallon of water,
and we sip on it all day.
And hopefully you finish
it by the end of the day.
So I'll drink a ton of water,
and go to the bathroom,
brush my teeth, and then
I meditate 20 minutes,
and then I exercise.
And that all happens before I go
off airplane mode on my phone.
SPEAKER: That's great.
Is there a podcast that
you feel like you've
learned the most from or
that's your favorite podcast?
I know you mentioned the one
about the loss of your father
and then Alex Benign was talking
about the loss of his father.
Is that your favorite podcast?
MIKE POSNER: Of my episodes?
SPEAKER: Of your episodes, yeah.
MIKE POSNER: I
really like that one.
And I really like the one,
which is just me talking
about my week in solitude.
Because I feel like I went
pretty deep in that one.
SPEAKER: Can you talk about
how the loss of your father
has affected you
over this past year?
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
In a myriad of ways,
the first of which
was pretty obvious,
which, it just reminded me
something I already knew
intellectually, which was I'm
next.
I'm going to die also,
and I don't know when.
So most people in this
room, including myself--
it changes.
But most of us have
a list of things
we want to do when we're done
doing what we have to do.
Just curious.
Raise of hands-- who has
one of those right now?
Don't be shy.
Just be yeah, like, I have one.
OK.
It's well over a
half the room, right?
And probably some of
the people are just shy.
I don't really believe you.
Most of us have something
we're putting off for later.
And I think that's
directly tied to the fact
that we are really
masterful in our culture
at pretending like we won't die.
You hear people say,
like, if I die--
it's like no.
It's not if, it's when.
And I'll bring it up
sometimes, and people will say,
don't bring that up right now.
I don't want to think
about that, which is fine.
You don't have to think
about it right now.
But if you never think
about it, what happens
is you live a life
where that list of later
gets longer and longer,
and it doesn't get done.
And the reason it
doesn't get done
is because you've
convinced yourself
you're not going to die.
Why would you do
it now if you're
going to live forever, right?
It makes sense you'd put it off.
You have unlimited time.
But that's not real.
You don't.
So the first way it
affected me was I just
started to do the things
off my list last year.
That's why I spent
that week alone
because that was on my list.
I had been wanting
to do that for years.
But it's, like, well, I have
to finish being popular first,
and then I can
spend my week alone.
SPEAKER: What else
is on the list?
MIKE POSNER: Some of the other
things that were on the list
that I did was I wanted
to see the woman that
wrote "Ask and It Is Given"--
she does speaking engagements,
and I wanted to go to one.
So I went to one of those.
I wanted to go back
to Burning Man.
Because I'd gone once
before, and I just loved it.
And I skipped a year
because I was on tour,
as being Mike Posner.
And so I went back.
There's a bunch more things.
There's a couple of
things I haven't done yet.
One is I want to spend
a month-long retreat
at a monastery somewhere.
And I plan on doing that.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: I'm sure I will.
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
I'm sure I will too.
SPEAKER: Do you feel
like doing these--
MIKE POSNER: I'm a weirdo.
SPEAKER: Do you feel
like doing these things--
you mentioned you put them off.
And you wanted to make it
before you did those things.
Do you feel like doing
these things actually
helps you in your musical career
as well because you come back,
and you're fresh, and
you're ready to make music.
Or do you feel like it's
a totally separate thing?
MIKE POSNER: No,
they're definitely tied.
My piano teacher,
one of my mentors--
rest in peace-- his name
was Norman Henry Mamey.
And he was telling me
a story about when he
used to work with his teacher.
And he would say, sometimes
I would go to the lesson--
and his teacher's
name was Edith Knox.
It was a strong lineage.
It's kind of important
in piano teaching.
And he said, I'd sit on the
piano bench next to Edith,
and we'd talk.
We have an hour
lesson, and we'd spend
50 minutes talking about
politics, sex, everything.
And he said, I started
to get frustrated
because we weren't playing.
So I asked her why
do we never play.
And she said, Norman, all
of that goes into this.
And I believe that.
Who you are as a human is
directly correlated to who
you are as an artist.
And that's not to say,
if you're a great guy,
and you start
making music, you're
going to be an amazing artist.
There's some skill involved.
Yeah.
You've got to practice.
But when you do
both, it matters.
I've been there.
I've done the opposite where
I've been in the studio
for a year and not
really done anything
else-- like,
basketball and studio.
And there have been points
where I just realized--
I'm writing songs.
And I'm like, these are all
lies because I don't do anything
in my life.
And there's no authenticity
in my music because all I do
is make music.
And there's nothing for
me to really talk about
except for making music.
So it's a balance.
And I always feel like I have
this mandate, especially now.
I shouldn't say always.
I feel like in the
last five years,
I have this mandate
from my audience.
And my audience pays my bills.
And they've paid me--
God bless them--
to a point where I
don't have to make more money.
So-- and I bring that
up-- it's a sleazy thing
to talk about tied to art.
But it actually
is important to me
because now I get to
ask the questions.
I don't have to work.
So what is life about if
you don't have to work?
And I feel like they're
paying me to ask that question
and report back.
And that's my job.
So I think that
stuff is important.
But also, the reporting
back is important.
So I don't think--
whenever I go and do these
experiments out of curiosity,
I never feel like I'm not
going to come back, and talk
about it, and share about it.
That's important to me too.
And I realized that a
lot when I was alone.
It's like, Mike, you
do these cool things
just so you can be the guy that
said you did the cool thing.
But you don't share
what you actually
got out of it with anyone.
And so that's a big part of
it is sharing what I got.
And I want to thank
you for allowing me--
I hope I've done a
little bit of that.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Absolutely.
It's been amazing.
Final question is
Jordan Peterson--
who we were talking
about earlier,
who you are a big fan
of, and I am as well--
talks about actually this
kind of future authoring
exercise where you
write about what you're
going to do in the future.
And you talked about on your--
you had a podcast
about the new year,
and what are you going to
do in the next three, four,
or five years and
hold yourself to that.
So what does Mike Posner look
like in five years from now?
MIKE POSNER: Oh, man, who knows?
But I know there's some things
I want to do or accomplish.
I want to win one of those
Grammys still, for sure.
I'm thinking about doing
a really long walk.
SPEAKER: Just a walk.
MIKE POSNER: I'm not sure yet.
Yeah.
Like maybe across America or--
like, a long one.
SPEAKER: That's long.
MIKE POSNER: Yeah,
it's 6 to 12 months
depending on how fast you go.
SPEAKER: Wow.
Is that bad for your knees?
MIKE POSNER: I don't know.
I think it's-- what I've heard,
it's really hard on your feet.
So to get ready for
it, they recommend
wearing no shoes, make
you feel stronger.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MIKE POSNER: Those
are maybe five years.
And then on the shorter
term, like this year,
I'm reading every day.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
MIKE POSNER: I missed
reading novels or whatever.
So yeah, I'm reading every day.
It can just be 10
minutes, five minutes.
But it ends up being more.
But that's my shorter term
this year thing I'm doing.
SPEAKER: Cool.
You guys want to do a
little audience Q&A?
MIKE POSNER: Don't be shy.
SPEAKER: Don't be shy.
Anybody have any questions?
MIKE POSNER: Damn,
whopping nothing.
Yay.
SPEAKER: You just speak into it?
Is that right, Justin?
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Apologies in advance
if you've probably
talked about this a lot online.
MIKE POSNER: It's OK.
AUDIENCE: But I never thought
to search, and now I get to ask.
I was debating with
my sister recently
about your song "Cooler
Than Me" because she
came on to you recently, and
was like, oh, this is super--
MIKE POSNER: She came onto me.
AUDIENCE: I've been
liking his music for ages.
And we were disagreeing
about what the message was
or what it was about.
And my interpretation
was, oh, it's really
about this guy's projection of
who he thinks this woman is,
and it's more about
his reactions to it
and his self versus a
portrait of this woman.
And so I was wondering,
when you were writing it,
what did you think it was about?
MIKE POSNER: No.
I'm formulating my thoughts.
Because it's
interesting the way you
phrased the question, is
when I was writing it,
what did I think.
I didn't think that.
I just thought the girls
weren't as nice to me
as they should be.
But hearing what you
said so eloquently,
that's probably a little
closer to the truth, right?
And this woman, whoever she
is, has her own insecurity
going on.
And, of course,
that's not who she is.
There's definitely
more to her story
than I'm giving her the
time of day in that song.
And a lot of my songs,
as I listen back to them,
are really pretty
embarrassingly sexist.
And I don't think it's funny.
People are requesting
something--
I have this song called "Bow
Chicka Wow Wow" with Lil Wayne.
SPEAKER: Lil Wayne on it, yeah.
MIKE POSNER: It's just
terribly misogynistic.
And I don't think about
it because you write it,
and then you move on.
But I was at a show, and
someone requested it,
and I start singing it, and I
was like, whoa, I wrote this?
And yeah.
I feel like a different guy.
I'm proud that I'm changing
and growing to the point
where I would never
write that now.
But that's where I was then.
So you didn't really
ask about that.
But I think what I was
thinking at the time was
different from what you said.
But I think what you said
is probably more accurate.
That was really going on.
And Mike had a lot
of insecurities
at the time as well,
and still does.
AUDIENCE: Well, it makes
it a more nuanced song,
if it's about the singer himself
than about that portrait.
But either way, it's
a really cool song.
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
And there's no right answer.
Kind of like the
obnoxious artist answer
is that's not my job.
It's the audience's job to
figure out what it's about.
Just write it.
AUDIENCE: It's a fun job.
MIKE POSNER: But my first
answer still stands.
Yeah.
I think you can throw it, right?
It's soft?
I think so.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
You have a really cool
zen vibe about you
that I didn't fully
know or expect.
So it's very cool to--
MIKE POSNER: I appreciate that.
Don't worry.
I have my moments.
I have this neighbor that
I lived next door to.
I live close to
here in [INAUDIBLE]..
And a lot of times I'll eat--
I have a little porch.
And I'll go out there in
the sun, and I'll eat.
And every time I'm on that
porch, I'm chilling, you know.
And she says, like,
I feel like you are--
you make me want to
be a better person.
You're so angelic, and
you're always so relaxed.
And I'm like, nah, that's
just my porch vibe.
Don't worry.
I have nervous
breakdowns sometimes.
Sorry to interrupt you.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
It's cool.
And you definitely brought
the porch vibe here
to this office, which I think
is a pretty cool vibe too.
MIKE POSNER: Cool.
Yeah, I agree.
AUDIENCE: Actually, I
have a question for you
about misogyny in hip hop.
Because I'm a huge hip hop fan.
I grew up on Tupac.
My brother was friends with
Lil Wayne down in New Orleans.
So we've been surrounded
by it my whole life.
And maybe it's
because I'm a mom now.
But when I listen
to some of the songs
I used to listen to,
or even Big Sean,
or whoever's on
the radio, I wonder
if I'm betraying
sort of my feminism
because of what they're saying.
I might love the beat.
I was listening to
G-Eazy yesterday.
And I was like, oh, my god.
I can't-- I want
to like the song,
but I'm so mad at this song.
And I wonder if you struggle
with that yourself as someone
who's evolving, or
if that's something
you talk about with these
amazing people you work with.
Because there's a
lot of women in here,
that, if we just stopped
listening to the music,
I wonder what would
happen to the music.
I wonder if we
could change things.
But I also wonder if
there's a conversation
that you men are having.
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
I haven't had it with
any of those guys.
I probably should.
And as you were speaking,
I'm reminded of--
I think it was Kanye
first said, I'm
not going to say gay or
fag in my songs anymore.
SPEAKER: I think he had
a cousin who was gay.
And that-- yeah.
MIKE POSNER: And then I
feel like-- maybe I'm wrong.
I don't listen as
closely to hip hop
as I used to-- not even close.
So maybe you could help me.
SPEAKER: I'll [INAUDIBLE]
on it, for sure.
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
But moving on, it seemed
like that rippled out.
And from my
perspective, those words
got used less across the
whole genre after he did that.
And so to me, it's like someone
needs to step up like that
and just say I'm not
going to do that anymore.
And I feel like people
would follow it.
Because it doesn't
really make sense.
It doesn't make--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Why are we still
talking about this?
MIKE POSNER: I'm sure
if you speak with them,
they wouldn't speak that way.
And to me, it's become this--
what's the word?
You can help me out.
I can't think of--
SPEAKER: Contrived.
Just for show.
MIKE POSNER: Not
contrived, like a go-to,
almost, like,
crutch in the music.
SPEAKER: The crut-- right.
MIKE POSNER: The
crutch isn't the word,
but I think you know
what I'm trying to say.
It's something people--
SPEAKER: A gimmick.
No.
MIKE POSNER: No.
The word isn't--
it doesn't matter.
But it's something people
just have done in the music,
and people are doing it
just because it's been done.
And I think that's as
deep as it goes, honestly.
It's like a tradition.
AUDIENCE: It's ingrained.
MIKE POSNER: It's an ingrained
tradition that is outdated.
It's antiquated.
And still, even some of my
newer music that I've written I
find from--
stuff I wrote two years
ago, which [INAUDIBLE]
catching stuff.
So I think, yeah.
Each artist has to take
that listener for sure.
But I think--
I don't know.
Maybe it's all the above.
But I think a big
artist stepping up
would make a difference.
I do.
And as far as, do
I feel that tear?
Yeah, I do.
Because some of it's so good.
Me and my buddy Nick, we were
listening to this guy XXX.
How do you say it [? Cancion? ?]
AUDIENCE: [? Cancion? ?]
MIKE POSNER: I can't say it.
But it's really good.
It's amazing angry music.
It's the highest quality angry
music, but it makes me angry.
And so the book I'm reading
right now is Chuck Palahniuk.
He wrote "Fight Club."
It's amazing-- the highest
quality dark novel.
But I'm entertained, but is it
messing me up, consuming this?
I don't know.
It's a question we have
to grapple with, I think,
individually.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's up, guys?
MIKE POSNER: What's up?
SPEAKER: How's it going?
AUDIENCE: So I just wanted
to say thanks for coming.
Thanks for spending
time with us.
One of my favorite
songs of yours
is "Wonder Why" on the Wale
Back to the Future mixtape.
MIKE POSNER: Oh, sick.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That was dope.
MIKE POSNER: Deep cut.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, man.
MIKE POSNER: Big Sean,
produced by 9th Wonder.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That was hot, man.
And so earlier on, you talked
a little bit about truth.
And then you guys
both mentioned to be
fans of Jordan Peterson, who is
amazing and just a fantastic--
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
I would say also, I don't
agree with everything
Jordan Peterson says.
But I'm a fan of--
he brings up a discussion
and gets me to think.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And so--
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
Just wanted to say that.
AUDIENCE: I hear you.
I was just going to ask,
in Jordan's dialogue,
he talks a lot about the
strengthening of the individual
as opposed to the
weakening of society.
If you want to make it, you
have to really work on yourself
as opposed to trying
to change others.
And for me, that was a
really big profound truth.
There was something
that I'd never
really given much thought to.
And so he so eloquently
talked about it.
And so I was just
curious if you had
any similar takeaways
from Jordan's discussions
or dialogues.
MIKE POSNER: Man, I think
I've probably had several.
But yeah, that's definitely
one of them, which is like--
actually, there's another one.
Instead of expounding
on yours, I'm
going to bring up
a separate thing
I've gotten from him, which
he was talking about marriage.
And he said, if you think
you might leave your partner,
you're not really married.
And he said, to play some
games, you have to be all in,
which is a really
interesting concept.
And he says, the interesting
thing about life,
for all of us, is we're all in.
He says this is going to kill
us whether we like it or not.
At the game of life, you're
going to die at the end.
So what are you going
to do with your time?
How are you going to play?
That resonated with me a lot.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Any other questions?
Right there?
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Hi.
MIKE POSNER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: And thank you
for that picture earlier.
MIKE POSNER: You're welcome.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Liliana.
MIKE POSNER: Liliana-- Mike.
Nice to meet you.
AUDIENCE: Nice to meet you.
So I have two questions.
One, because they posted
it on social media,
there's a question--
I'll just ask it first because
that's what they want to know.
But how much do you charge
when you create music,
like, Justin Bieber's
boyfriend, for example.
Not my question.
MIKE POSNER: Is that the
new way of saying like, I
have a friend, you know--
AUDIENCE: No.
No.
Honest.
MIKE POSNER: No.
I actually believe you.
AUDIENCE: I'll ask
you my question after.
MIKE POSNER: No.
I believe you.
I really wanted to make a joke.
But typically, how
that stuff works is
it's largely based on royalties.
So you get a percentage,
depending on how many people
wrote the song.
I'm a big proponent of, if
there are four guys in the room,
you just split it even.
Sometimes people get into this
thing where, I wrote 30 lines,
and you wrote 29, so I
should get this much.
That always gets icky to me.
I like to just do it even.
And so basically, you
get paid a percentage
of whatever money comes in.
For producers, it's
a little different.
A producer, depending
on who it is,
gets an advance,
which means they
get paid the money upfront.
And then as the money
comes in, the other person
gets that advance paid
back, and then they
get the profits after that.
So advance for
producers can range.
If it's your first beat you're
ever selling, typically, going
rate is, like, $5,000, I think.
You'd probably know
better than me.
But a new producer--
$5,000 to $10,000
would be an advance.
And then I don't know
what the high end is now.
Back in the days when people
were buying more music,
like Scott Storch--
these guys sell a
track for $1 million.
But I think that's gone down
because people buy less music.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Now, my question.
MIKE POSNER: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: OK.
So at the beginning
of the talk, you
mentioned how maybe global
warming is something really
important, but maybe
it doesn't really
matter because we're getting
in the way of something
much larger.
So then, when you think
about things like that,
then how do you decide
what really matters?
MIKE POSNER: Yeah.
I'm not sure anything does.
There are things definitely
that matter to me.
Like, my mom matters to me.
But there is that
in the background,
like why does it matter that
your mom matters to you?
If I just cut her off,
which I never would do,
does that matter in the
great scheme of things?
And the answer is we don't know.
We don't have perspective
enough to tell.
Yeah.
If we had, like, a God
perspective, we could see.
The Bible says, that thou
shall not kill, right?
It sounds reasonable, right?
I don't kill people.
But what if, like, the person
was about to kill two people?
Then, is it OK?
So these things get
icky really quickly.
And somebody would say no.
But what if they were about
to kill a million people?
I don't know.
It's very nuanced.
And we don't have the
perspective to see what--
AUDIENCE: So does
that get in the way
of your happiness every day?
If you're making
decisions, do you
think about it broadly like--
MIKE POSNER: At times.
There's an EB White quote
that says, "I wake up
in the morning, and I don't
know whether to save the world
or savor it.
This makes it hard
to start the day."
And yeah.
I feel that sometimes.
But it's waves.
Sometimes I go, well, I'm just
going to play my guitar a lot
today.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
MIKE POSNER: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Anybody else?
All right.
Thank you so much for coming.
MIKE POSNER: Thank you, guys.
SPEAKER: We really
appreciate it.
MIKE POSNER: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you, Mike.
It was awesome.
MIKE POSNER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]